lots and looks incredibly stupid  incredibly awful the man do I want to  watch that [ __ ] not so I could walk out  of the movie bitching about it but  because I feel like I'll have a great  time watching it it's Arnold [ __ ]  Schwarzenegger for crying out loud  jingle all the way yes that is my shitty  Arnold impersonation sure the guy's done  some other things this past decade but  all we've really wanted for a minutes to  return to cinema making fun  cheesy ridiculously over-the-top bad  action movies again excluding Terminator  2 with this trailer it looks like  exactly what we want from Arnold him  joining the league of extraordinarily  old action stars plus Johnny Knoxville  reprises his role from walking tall in  the end this trailer looks like a lot of  intentionally bad fun action which is  exactly what I want from this movie in  the end Ryan Wright thinks this film  will get it right dish  you